nous reprenons la séance avec
le plaisir d'accueillir madame
chrysolazakhiropoulou secrétaire d'État
auprès de la ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères chargés du
développement de la Francophonie et des
partenariats internationaux c'est la
première fois madame la ministre que
nous avons le plaisir de vous entendre
en séance plénière on a eu quelques
difficultés à trouver une date commune
mais enfin nous y sommes parvenus et en
l'occurrence cette audition revêt une
importance toute particulière dans la
mesure où depuis longtemps nous
souhaitions faire le point avec vous sur
l'aide publique au développement je
rappelle que c'est quand même une
politique très importante dotée de
crédit en hausse continue désormais tout
aussi important que les moyens que nous
consacrons à notre diplomatie il était
donc important et essentiel même d'avoir
un interlocuteur ministériel dédié le
Sénat avait à plusieurs reprises sous le
précédent quinquennat
souhaité
avait fait savoir que nous souhaitions
bien évidemment qu'un ministre puisse
diriger ce secteur essentiel alors
madame mamie on a plusieurs pour que
l'on souhaiterait évoquer avec vous tout
d'abord le Conseil présidentiel du
développement qui s'est réuni le 5 mai
dernier après la promulgation de la loi
de l'orientation et de programmation
solidarité internationale lors de cette
séance plusieurs nouvelles orientations
sont été décidées ce sont des
orientations qui font la part belle à la
lutte contre le changement climatique la
sortie du charbon le financement des
énergies renouvelables dans les pays en
voie de développement sont même le
premier de la liste des objectifs
validés par le Président de la
République nous sommes aussi satisfaits
de retrouver dans cette liste
l'éducation et la formation des
professeurs ou encore la souveraineté
alimentaire en Afrique
dont nous avons et j'ai moi-même eu
l'occasion de dire à plusieurs reprises
que ça restait un point absolument
essentiel le relevé de décision du
Conseil présidentiel met également
l'accent sur une nouvelle stratégie
d'investissement solidaire et durable
des ISD vous nous expliquerez en quoi
réside la nouveauté de cette approche en
particulier quels sont ces liens avec le
nouveau pack financier
issu du sommet de Paris le 23 juin
dernier
par ailleurs madame la ministre ces
nouveaux objectifs doivent être déclinés
dans le prochain suicide que nous
attendons toujours on me parle du 13
juillet 13 juillet comme date
de tenue de ce comité le dernier datant
je le rappelle quand même de 2018 alors
comment se suicide va s'articuler avec
le Conseil présidentiel de développement
qui fixe ses propres objectifs et ses
propres indicateurs donc ça c'est un
sujet important
par ailleurs la Cour des comptes a
publié en janvier dernier un rapport
relatif à la comparaison des APD
française allemand des Britanniques la
Cour a considère notamment que nous
financements multilatéraux sont
insuffisamment fléchés au profit des
priorités de la politique française
d'APD en comparaison avec le
Royaume-Uni ou l'Allemagne la manière
dont il le pratique est-ce que vous
prévoyez donc de faire évoluer la
doctrine française sur ce point en
fléchant davantage nos contributions non
obligatoires afin de reprendre le
contrôle de financement enfin on se doit
évidemment d'évoquer la mise en place de
la commission d'évaluation
serpent de mer créés par la loi du 4
août 2021 il est inconcevable que cette
commission ne soit pas en activité près
de 2 ans après sa création après
l'étrange épisode de la dernière loi de
finance sur la question de l'attribution
ou non de la présidence des commissions
au premier président de la Cour des
comptes ou en sommes-nous aujourd'hui je
pense qu'une malheureusement ces choses
n'avancent pas très loin puisque j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer la mise à faire
étrangères avec mon collègue Jean-Louis
bourlan sur ce problème et que pour
l'instant
on ne voit pas dans le contexte
législatif actuel comment les choses
peuvent bouger voilà quelques quelques
éléments d'interrogations puis ce sera
complété évidemment par nos rapporteurs
huxury Rachid themal mais je vous
propose de prendre la parole pour 10 15
minutes et puis après nous aurons une
séance de questions et de réponse madame
la ministre bienvenue chez nous et vous
avez la parole merci beaucoup monsieur
le président
bonjour madame et monsieur le sénateur
avant d'évoquer les sujets alors que je
porte j'aimerais vous dire à vous et aux
élus locaux qui vous représentez mon
plus grand soutien il m'a pleine
solidarité face aux événements de ces
dernières jours dans ces moments où la
démocratie est attaquée vous aurez un
rôle indispensable et courageux pour
amener des dialogues apaisés apaiser les
choses et trouver des solutions du fond
ces événements nous rappellent qu'il est
hyperactif d'être uni à toute
circonstances pour répondre aux
préoccupations des non-CO citoyens et
bien sûr c'est la nécessite un dialogue
régulière alors justement Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénataires j'aimerais au
cours de cette audition échangée avec
vous sous l'action que je mène au
service de la politique étrangère du
président de la République et de la
première ministre et auprès de la
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères Catherine colonne
le monde il est en train de changer
les crises c'est superposent
la pandémie les crises financières les
changements climatiques la guerre à
l'Ukraine et ses conséquences mondiales
les grandes vision du monde s'affrontent
il y a donc un grand risque de
fracturation
et qui conduirait au monde des cinq ans
pour soi
non concitoyens sont très préoccupés ils
nous demandent d'agir sur des sujets
comme la lutte contre les inégalités la
lutte contre les changements climatiques
ou l'accès aux services publics
notamment dans les secteurs de la santé
et de l'éducation mais ces
préoccupations ne sont pas des
préoccupations françaises sont des
préoccupations universelles et je pile
observer lors de mes très nombreux
déplacements tous les États sont donc
confrontés à des enjeux similaires
pour y répondre il faut bien sûr
apporter des réponses au niveau national
et ce qui nous essayons d'y faire mais
ceci à l'international que nous devons
agir car Madame et Monsieur les
sénateurs c'est l'air de la
interdépendance et alors nous devons
faire un choix nous nous refusons les
repli nous nous refusons la paire de
l'autre et nous décidons de nous ouvrir
d'agir de chercher apaiser sur ces
nouveaux mondes c'est le choix du
président de la République accepter la
nouvelle donne bâtir des solutions et
chercher des alliés pour faire peser la
vision française du monde et tout cela
et pour cela pardon il faut parler à
tous
les mondes ne se décident plus au J7 il
n'a plus de petits pays il n'y a plus de
partenaires négligeables il y a les pays
émergents il y a les petites îles il y a
de nombreux acteurs qui souhaitent jouir
un rôle
important donc avec cinq ans nous devons
nouer avec sa canne nous devons nouer
des partenariats et ces partenariats
doivent permettre du défendre nos
intérêts nos intérêts économiques nos
intérêts matières de bien publics
mondiaux nos intérêts
de nos pays voisins
donc il faut aller partout il faut aller
partout pour convaincre parce qu'un peu
forte aujourd'hui c'est un pays qu'il a
des partenaires qu'il a des alliés voilà
alors le sens de ma mission bâtir les
partenariats internationaux dont nous
avons besoin pour relever nos défis et
défendre nos intérêts
pour bâtir alors ces partenariat
j'aimerais maintenant partager avec vous
après ma méthode que je mets à neuf
comme je vous le disais je vois qu'il
n'y a pas de petits pays et nous devons
parler à tous je vais partout
pour renforcer nos partenariats
stratégiques et voir changer par changer
comment nous pouvons mieux coopérer avec
chaque pays notamment face aux objets
globaux c'est pour cela que depuis
manomination en mai 2022 c'est Monsieur
rendu à plus de 55 pays y compris là où
on n'est jamais allé à la contrôler les
dirigeants mais aussi les acteurs de la
société civile et j'ai participé à tous
les grands rendez-vous et soyez
internationaux je vais vous donner des
exemples je suis allée un Papouasie
Nouvelle Guinée et au Vanuatu il de
pacifique qui n'avait plus réussi de
ministres français depuis quatre
décennies au cours de ces visites nous
avons
approfondie notre partenariat sur la
préservation de l'environnement mais
aussi notre partenariat stratégique dans
les cadres de notre stratégie en de
pacifique et bien sûr
l'intégration régionale des non
territoire d'outre-mer sujet que vous
connaissez bien
mais s'il est sanitaires de nouvelles
Calédonie autre exemple je noierai la
sur l'important avec la première
ministre de la Barbade madame miamotli
et j'ai été la première ministre
français de l'histoire à me rendre sur
cette île Madame Madeline nous a permis
de fortement renforcer l'ambition et les
codes du sommet sur les nouveaux parts
financiers mondial qui se tenir à Paris
il y a des semaines voilà parler à tout
le monde oui
mais parler avec une posture différente
je le vis sous les continents africains
mais pas seulement
nous
français nous devons être à l'écoute
nous devons être dans les dialogues dans
le respect de l'autre nous devons être
humble
en parlant chacun comme de partenaires
égaux et aussi avoir la l'humilité d'y
apprend des autres je l'ai souvent dit
la France n'a rien à imposer nulle part
et à des intérêts à négocier des
solutions à proposer comme aussi nos
partenaires bien sûr
quand nous parle de nos partenaires
internationaux les premières
et les centrales est le plus intral
d'entre eux c'est notre partenariat avec
le continent africains les présidents de
la République a placé depuis 2017 les
renouveau de notre partenariat avec les
continents africains au cœur de sa
politique étrangère parce que nous
sommes convaincus que ces continents qui
nous fait face à notre première
partenaire de croissance et nos
premières partenaires pour élever les
défis globaux nous sommes convaincus que
la relation entre France et Europe et
Europe et Afrique et au coeur des enjeux
géopolitiques d'aujourd'hui et du démon
et que c'est par l'axe et ourafiquants
qui nous pourrons peser au monde mais
attention il n'y a plus de précarité ou
d'exclusivité les pays africains
choisissent aujourd'hui leur partenaire
et si je peux dire tant mieux
un particulièrement face aux discours en
des Français c'est à nous maintenant de
leur montrer quel partenaire nous sommes
quel partenariat nous offrons au niveau
français mais aussi au niveau européen
et franchement nous nous avons un
partenariat très riche et très complet
qui offre qui soit au niveau français
mais aussi au niveau européen au pays
africains
nous offrons un partenariat comme je dis
à 360 degrés en partenariat de sécurité
du développement humanitaire économique
culturelle mais ces partenariats sont à
réinventer en appréhension par des
Africains et je reviendrai dans quelques
instants
et sur ça nous devons en toute état des
causes dire clairement qui nous sommes
et qui sont nos intérêts c'est une
demande qui nous pose et nous nous
devons avoir aussi le courage de
répondre c'est ça que je fais lors des
cinq ans de mes déplacements parfois
dans des situations particulièrement
difficiles car je me suis rendue au
Burkina Faso par exemple pour parler aux
autorités de transcision j'ai montré que
c'est je montrais qui nous sommes et
qu'est-ce qu'on peut offrir ou en RDC
pour défendre l'image de notre pays en
décembre dernière accusée des collusions
avec les Rwanda afin mon action nos
services des partenariats internationaux
consiste bien sûr à marquer l'engagement
français dans les instances
multilatérales rien que cette année nous
avons annoncé une contribution
historique au fond mondiale des lutte
contre les VIH la tuberculose c'est le
paludisme 1,8 milliards on est le
deuxième contrebuteur après les
États-Unis nous avons contribué avec nos
partenaires et européens en accord
historique pour la création de fonds
perte de dommages à la Convention nous
avons organisé avec les gabons à
Libreville one Sam qui a permis de
croître la mobilisation internationale
pour les préservations des forêts
tropicales où nous préparons avec les
Costa Rica où je me suis rendue la
conférence de l'ONU pour les océanes à
Nice en 2025 mais la France aussi
présente pour joindre rôle moteur et
pour un pulser des initiatives
multilatérales nouvelle originales je
pense et vous vous rappelez tous pendant
la pandémie l'initiative covacs que j'ai
eu l'honneur des coprésidée
ou encore à la coalition haute ambition
pour la protection des 30% des terres et
mer qui a été rejoindre par plus de 100
pays enfin
les meilleurs exemples de cette
politique des partenariats
internationaux c'est le sommet nouveau
pacte financiers qui nous avons tenir à
Paris la semaine dernière
ce sommets visé à unir pour la première
fois le monde du développement et le
monde de finances plus des sacsf d'état
des centaines des acteurs politiques
associatifs économique se sont retrouvés
à Paris pour affirmer que personne ne
doit avoir à choisir entre la lutte
contre la pauvreté et la lutte contre
les changements climatiques
mais voilà
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénataires
c'est celle-là la force et l'histoire de
la France être une fausse d'équilibre
qui perd unir tout le monde c'est pour
ça qu'ils sont venus et mobiliser ses
partenaires autour de nos défis comment
et la présence de tant de partenaires à
ces sommets prouvent que nous sommes
reconnus pour cela à Paris nous avons
créé des conseils sur porter de
coalitions et obtenir de nombreuses
avancées concrètes je ne vais pas entrer
dans les détails mais je vous soulignais
qui est désengagements passés on était
tenus sur le DTS par exemple ou un
accord très entendu sous la dette
zambienne elle était trouvée
des coalitions on était créé autour de
l'idée d'une taxe sur les émissions des
transports maritimes ou des clauses de
suspicion des services de la dette en
cas de catastrophes naturelles
ces sommets a créé une dynamique
politique que nous allons poursuivre et
amplifier lors des prochaines
rendez-vous internationaux notamment le
Yvan et la cop22 voilà donc en quelques
mots la méthode que je mets en oeuvre et
aussi la fierté de faire partie de cette
grande nation
après alors avoir parlé des méthodes
j'aimerais parler des outils que nous
avons pour mobiliser
des partenaires cet outil sont comme
vous avez dit mais si le président notre
politique de aide au développement mais
aussi la francophonie et bien sûr notre
place au centre de l'Union européenne
dans notre famille européenne qui est
notre force
notre politique développement c'est un
outil central de notre politique de
partenariat internationaux et de notre
politique étrangère depuis 2017
notre APD a augmenté de
50%, c'est une hausse historique la
France désormais les quatrième Bayern
mondiale dette publique au développement
cela doit avoir un impact positif sur
notre image sur notre fluence nos
intérêts et je me remercier le sénateur
ou que sorry et Rachid et mâle pour leur
travail de rapporteur pour avis auprès
de cette commission sur l'aide publique
développement les économies que
développement de la solidarité qui zone
alimentait le débat de la loi des
finances pour 2023 notre politique de
développement doit mieux répondre aux
enjeux de monde d'aujourd'hui c'est pour
cela que les 5 mai lors du Conseil
présidentiel de développement les
présidents de République nous a fixés de
orientation qui nécessite doit conforter
et j'ai beaucoup échangé la dessous en
nécessite avec les parlamentaires les
gélules locaux et la société civile dans
un contexte alors budgétaire
particulièrement difficile que vous
connaissez tous nous voulons avec
mialigner notre politique de
développement avec nos intérêts nos
valeurs et nos priorités politiques en
assumant la construction de partenariats
plus transactionnelle
renforcer notre agilité notamment à
personne la répartition géographique de
notre action concrètement cela veut dire
que peut investir sur tes projets en
Zambie par exemple démocratie africaine
qui veut travailler avec nous ou en
Papouasie comme je disais Nouvelle
Guinée acteur clé du Pacifique ensuite
il faut actualiser nos priorités
thématiques à la forçant notamment notre
prise en compte de la vulnérabilité
climatique ou encore les soutiennent à
les déprénaria et à la formation
professionnelle et bien sûr moderniser
nos instruments et nos moyens d'action
notamment pour mobiliser davantage le
secteur privé mais si la jeunesse de
notre pays pour que ça ne gage
pour créer des partenariats qu'il est
très cher à moi que je ne suis pas né
francophone c'est la francophonie je
sais d'après nos essences qui s'est jugé
est très important pour plusieurs
d'entre vous il est vite dément pour la
ministre à Colona et moi-même grâce au
plan langue français et plus riche
languisme lancé en 2018 par les
présidents de la République nous faisons
déjà énormément pour les rayonnements
l'apprentissage de l'autre langue
plusieurs rendez-vous importants nous
attend dans les prochaines mois tout
d'abord l'ouverture de la Cité
internationale de la langue française
dans les prochaines mois mais aussi ça
serait une maison la maison de tous les
francophones mais ça nous plaît les
prochaines sommets vers octobre 2024 de
l'OIF ou notre pays aura l'honneur de
acquérir
de vrais pour que ces sommets
favorise des nouvelles grandes avancées
notamment première faire connaître aux
Français les richesses qui offrent la
francophonie à travers cet espace
francophone avec 80 huit pays pour même
pour mieux mettre en valeur la langue
française et surtout cet espace
francophone qui est moi je dis c'est un
espace de porto-nitaire pour l'emploi
pour la formation la création les
tepreneuriat la coopération scientifique
et bien sûr pour mieux développer des
outils numériques francophones
sous la lutte contre les forces et
formations la question d'éducation
et j'aurais besoin de vous pour faire
vivre la francophonie partout
quand on parle des outils
je rappelle
sans cesse comme vous pouvez comprendre
demande histoire personnelle qui font
passer nos partenariats au niveau
européen
pas seulement par mon parcours mais
j'étais par la Météor européenne et je
me suis engagée en politique pour
défendre l'Europe la France et l'Europe
et pour défendre une Europe géopolitique
qui porte sa voie et ses valeurs partout
qui pèsent et qui agit avant cette c'est
tout logique
des sommets par exemple de l'Union
européenne Union africaine qu'il a été
organisé lors de la présidence française
des conseils à février 2021 Bruxelles
mais une Europe géolique c'est aussi
l'objectif d'investissement global
Gateway 300 milliards
150 milliards seulement pour l'Afrique
et je vois aussi qui ça c'est notre
force c'est pour ça j'organisais ok
dossier avec 300 été prises
et la commission pour qui on peut
s'expliquer à nos entreprises comment
ils peuvent utiliser mieux cet outil
voilà
et pas seulement dans un moment
difficile et vous savez tous
comment aujourd'hui les autres pays les
rousses en particulier et les Chinois
les tours ils ont partout par exemple
sur les continents africains alors moi
j'essaye et je suis très fière de vous
dire que j'organise des déplacements en
équipe Europe que nous porter plions
pour montrer
que c'est là notre force
afin mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
je suis convaincu que nous avons tous
une part apprend dans la construction de
nos partenariats internationaux ces
partenariat ne se font pas simplement
entre États ne se font pas entre
gouvernement mais il faut qu'il se joue
à tous les niveaux nos scientifiques
n'ont été prises nos artistes tous
honorent la joie pour créer ses
partenariats gagnants gagnants à travers
le monde je les redis souvent y compris
lorsque je me déplace sur les
territoires nationales mais bien sûr
ces partenariats
c'est nous aussi grâce à nous
parlamentaires à nos sénateurs à travers
votre diplomatie à laquelle je crois
beaucoup et que je tiens le soutenir
mais si à nos collectivités
territoriales que j'ai rencontré un
corps c'est lundi et qui joue un rôle
indispensable en matière de coopération
et bien sûr grâce à la société civile
nous avons tous un rôle à jouer nous
devons toujours répondre à cette envie
de France parce que oui mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs il y a une envie
de France je peux vous le confirmer
après 55 pays il y a et votre fier de
notre pays oui il y a une envie de
travailler avec nous de bénéficier de
tout ça qui nous faisons de notre
savoir-faire alors voilà
je tenais monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs à vous
présenter comme vous avez dit cette
action que je menais depuis 13 mois je
tiens à souligner que j'échange avec
vous régulièrement et notamment les
présidents de cette commission vos idées
votre préoccupation vous remontez merci
nos débats nos discussions sont très
précieuses pour moi ma porte vous savez
Harry de la convention est toujours
ouverte tant pour
nos territoires à l'action
internationale et nous avons aussi cette
tous ensemble cette mission d'expliquer
à nos concitoyens qu'est-ce que nous
faisons et aussi
j'ai un envie de bouger aussi y compris
lors de mes déplacements parce que comme
je vous le disais au début
le plus important face à ces défis aussi
vertigineux c'est d'être uni c'est
d'agir ensemble parce que mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs nous sommes tous
en dehors des couleurs politiques
l'équipe France est nous devons être
fier merci
merci madame la ministre pour cette
présentation générale
je pense qu'à travers les questions de
nos rapporteurs vous aurez l'occasion de
repréciser
les questions que j'ai moi-même posées
notamment sur la sur la commission
d'évaluation et sur les orientations du
suicide je vais donc tout de suite
passer la parole à nos rapporteurs
Hugues se répuirachent les mâles
je vais répondre à vos questions où j'ai
merci président madame la madame la
ministre merci pour votre présence merci
pour vos propos je vous rassure nous
sommes tous ici fiers de notre de notre
pays pour ma part pour ma part donc j'ai
plusieurs questions à vous poser lors
des débats concernant la loi du 4 août
2021 sur le développement solidaire nous
étions tous d'accord pour dire que la
priorité des priorités c'était la lutte
contre la pauvreté c'est-à-dire si on
résume manger se soigner s'éduquer pour
cela nous avions approuvé le fait qu'il
y ait des pays prioritaires 19 au total
18 pays africains plus Haïti
or il semblerait que par décision du
Conseil présidentiel du développement le
suicide dont vous venez que vous venez
d'évoquer ne désignera plus une liste de
pays prioritaires et mais en même temps
vous venez d'insister sur le partenariat
avec les pays du continent africain donc
je ne me demande s'il n'y a pas une
contradiction
est-ce que les objectifs de lutte contre
le changement climatique qui sont certes
essentiels mais qui concerne moins les
pays les plus pauvres pour l'atténuation
ne risque pas de faire passer les
objectifs de lutte contre la pauvreté au
second plan c'est ma première question
ensuite le président a évoqué le rapport
de la Cour des comptes et j'ai plusieurs
interrogations à ce sujet également
la Cour des comptes comme souvent est
critique vis-à-vis de l'organisation du
contrôle de l'AFD il estime notamment
que les FD s'apparente davantage à une
agent de scie à l'américaine c'est à
dire qui participe à la conception d'une
politique publique mais qui est aussi
partie prenante dans son application
or la cour de court jusque le contrôle
rapproché auquel tente de se soumettre
les deux ministères compétents et très
difficiles au vu notamment des moyens
humains disponibles qui ne sont pas qui
ne sont pas immenses la cour suggère
d'en prendre acte en allégeant les
procédures de compte-rendues à court
terme et en mettant en place un examen
approfondi tous les deux ans des projets
engagés pour notre part nous estimons
que le suivi des activités de l'agence
doit être non pas allégée mais au
contraire renforcé nous espérons
particuliers que votre désignation au
poste de secrétaire d'État ce que nous
avions souhaité dédié donc secrétaire
d'État dédié va dans ce sens est-ce bien
le cas que pensez-vous de cette idée
d'un examen approfondie biennale
n'est-ce pas un rôle qui pourrait être
confié à la nouvelle commission
d'évaluation si celle-ci effectivement
voit enfin le jour et nous sommes pour
le moins étonnés que près de deux ans
après l'adoption de la loi donc sur le
développement solitaire voté à
l'unanimité par les deux Chambres
celle-ci cette commission n'est toujours
pas été constituée
le troisième point c'est toujours en
lien avec le rapport de la Cour des
comptes qui pointe également le
caractère inadéquate de l'organisation
de l'APD dans les pays destinataires
avec un conseiller à l'action culturelle
et de coopération censés conseiller
l'ambassadeur mais n'ayant que très peu
de moyens financiers par rapport
notamment au directeur local de la FD
qui dispose de moyens sans commune
mesure avec les siens et Enrique qui est
en réalité le véritable chef de la
coopération et donc la cour suggère de
mettre fin à cette situation
insatisfaisante en faisant
officiellement du directeur ASD le
conseiller développement de
l'ambassadeur qu'en pensez-vous est-ce
que cela ne permettrait pas
effectivement de mieux harmoniser
l'action de l'AFD avec les priorités du
Quai d'Orsay en renforçant finalement
l'autorité de l'ambassadeur sur l'agence
et puis le quatrième sujet que
rapidement que je l'ai évoqué c'était le
débat sur la taxe sur les transactions
financières les TTF au niveau européen
qui a été relancé récemment au Parlement
européen et
qui donc c'est un sujet pour lequel la
Commission a demandé au stade membre
d'avancer rapidement or il semble que la
France ne soit pas très allante sur ce
sujet notamment parce que on peut
imaginer qu'une TTF européenne aurait
sans doute un taux plus élevé ou une
assiette plus large que la TTF française
actuelle et donc pouvez-vous préciser la
position de la France sur ce sujet voilà
je vous remercie
alors madame Lamy si vous le voulez bien
je vais d'animer ce débat qui est tout à
fait intéressant et qui était très
attendu je vais vous proposer de
répondre à chaque orateur à la suite
mais je demande de calibrer vos réponses
parce que d'abord j'ai une liste
d'intervenants assez importante et après
nous avons de nouveau un rapport
j'insiste du reste sur la première
partie de la question de notre
rapporteur x horrible parce que
effectivement dans dans les propos que
vous avez tenus
j'y vois un certain décalage avec ce que
la Commission pense notamment
vis-à-vis des nécessités qu'il y a moi
je veux bien que on donne comme priorité
le climat la seule chose c'est que nous
qui voyons très souvent des
représentants de ces pays nous dit c'est
quand même pas à nous qu'il faut imputer
le dérèglement du climat dans le monde
et je pense que les priorités restent
toujours dans nombre de pays
c'est de leur donner de quoi manger de
quoi se nourrir et de quoi se former
donc votre c'est très important parce
que
nous voyons dans ces propos la marque de
l'AFD ce que nous connaissons bien et
sur lequel je souhaite que vous puissiez
dire clairement votre sentiment voilà si
vous voulez bien je vous laisse la
parole pour répondre à X horrible puis
après on passera à richesse
mais c'est pour vos questions là il y a
je pense
beaucoup de choses alors
comme j'ai dit à mes propos
si on a fait les sommets pour le nouvel
pacte c'était exactement pour éviter
d'y opposer les changements climatiques
et la lutte contre la pauvreté ne sont
pas des choses différentes si on pense
les conséquences des changements
climatiques c'est celui-ci qui fait
déplacer par exemple
le donner une stabilité mais aussi ce
synonyme de la pauvreté alors au
contraire et c'est la préoccupation de
toutes les pays il faut jamais opposer
ça et c'est pour ça aussi aujourd'hui le
monde des Nations Unies et les mondes
finances New York ils sont venus ici
pour travailler sur ça
et ensuite
et vous m'avez parlé de changement de de
pays prioritaires très bien pourquoi
qu'est-ce que ça va changer et
les CPD
il donne alors la priorité au pays des
mois avancés ça veut dire c'est pas que
on supprime le 19 sans le replacer mais
on mis au coeur les pays les mois
avancés et si on voit là si les CPI
concentrent les besoins les défis et les
crises ils sont la moitié de la
population mondiale en situation de
l'extrême pauvreté il se trouve dans
cette catégorie et la plupart c'est
liste de 19 pays si vous allez voir sur
les paiements ils sont là à l'intérieur
de cette catégorie alors cette nouvelle
cible qu'on a voulu élargir
avec les avec
en mettant la priorité pays les moins
avancées
prouvent que la rééducation de la
pauvreté comme vous avez dit reste entre
de nos objectifs principaux
ensuite vous m'avez demandé sur la
question
c'était
OK
très bien
alors le président de la République et
le gouvernement et vous imaginez très
bien moi-même
nous sommes très attachés à un pilotage
politique que ce soit efficace qui soit
aussi cohérente soit lisible pour tous
et ces agissons de l'AFD
comme vous savez bien c'est un opérateur
de mise en oeuvre et sur la totalité de
l'État comme l'établi clairement la loi
d'autres 2021
alors la ministre moi-même nous sommes
attachés à cette
pilotage politique précis afin que
l'action de l'AFD soit bien alignée avec
nos priorités et nos valeurs et nos
intérêts d'aujourd'hui aussi et
comment nous exerçons je vais vous dire
qu'est-ce que je fais depuis mon arrivée
moi je tiens les comités
environ tous les deux mois avec les
trésors avec les directions générales de
trésor avec la Direction générale de la
mondialisation
et tous les administrations sont là et
ensuite nous pilotons finement la
répartition géographique des crédits
budgétaires importants à louer à l'AFD
pour qu'il correspondent parfaitement à
nos priorités et afin vous savez bien
qu'il est affaire atteindre sa voie
conseil d'administration de la FD ok le
Parlement aussi représentés alors
comme je suis très attachée
au renforcement du pilotage de notre
dispositif aussi sur les terrains via
nos ambassades
je pense que nous avons de très bons
expertises de capacités financières
importantes mais manque accord cette
coordination ce travail d'équipe France
que j'essaye de piano de donner cette
réflexe et personnellement je ne suis
pas favorable
sur vous m'avez proposé sur la question
du coca du cocaques et qui est le
directeur de l'agence prend ses troll le
président de la République il a dit que
les chefs d'orchestre
doit être l'ambassadeur il faut
renforcer aussi avec l'état de la
diplomatie les rôles de l'ambassadeur on
a c'est pour cette raison aussi que vous
avez dit pour les cocaques on a créé on
a pris des financements si vous voulez
dans l'Agence française de développement
et on a redonné aux ambassades avec un
nouveau fond qui s'appelle équipe France
pour que les Ambassadors à travers des
projets qui font monter les cocaques
pisse et puissent agir vite et moi même
personnellement
dans quelques jours quand tous les coca
qui vont venir je vais renforcer que
vous avez totalement raison les rôles
parce qu'on a eu un petit peu un rôle
qu'il était un petit peu mieux un peu
moins et avec moins évident mais que
c'était des personnes qui connaissent
très bien les terrains sont des grandes
expertises et aussi c'est la politique
qui décide
vous voyez alors je pense qu'il faut
respecter ça
ensuite
la dernière question vous m'avez posé
c'était sur la taxation
la TTF
alors vous savez très bien que notre
pays pionnière à ma tête de taxation
innovante pour financer la solidarité
internationale nous avons une taxe qu'il
était par les présidents Chirac sur le
billet d'avion
et depuis 2012 une taxe sur les
transactions financières
une part importante de cet axe finance
notre action en matière des santé
mondiale la loutre contre le sida mais
aussi notre action climatiques à
l'internationale maintenant vous savez
que
cet axe de transactions financières a
montré quand même et son efficacité et
elle contribue chaque année à hauteur de
528 millions à notre effort de
solidarité internationale
maintenant l'argile c'est des enclencher
une dynamique internationale une
dynamique de nos partenaires comme vous
avez dit et européenne de OC2 de tous
les pays et c'était aussi une discussion
que nous avons eu il y a deux semaines
ici à Paris c'est un des objets du
sommets pour un nouveau pacte financière
ça veut dire quand même
il faut commencer à penser comme par
exemple nous avons amplifié la dynamique
de la taxation du secteur maritime qui
aujourd'hui il ne participe pas zérotax
alors sous les sagement climatiques et
sur les conséquences voilà la France sur
ça et porte cette voie et et après le
rendez-vous de
cette nouveau pacte on va un peu faire
dans le tournée du monde dit promouvoir
cet été que je pense qui est il a montré
à notre pays qui marche alors ça peut
marcher aussi aux autres pays
voilà merci Madame la mise alors
monsieur était mal
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame
Miss d'être présente et effectivement
c'est une une demande ancienne duxury de
moi-même de vous de vous avoir ici pour
avoir cette audition moi j'ai un
problème d'abord globalement voilà
le problème c'est que j'avais cru mais
dans mes cours de quand j'étais jeune
que le Parlement faisait la loi et elle
s'appliquait malheureusement on a
travaillé sur la loi du 4 août 2021 je
vous passe d'ailleurs le fait que elle
soit intervenue apprend à après même
l'entrée en matière de d'un nouveau plan
parce que il y a même pas de financement
sur les premières années et donc il doit
aller jusqu'en 2025 donc cette loi a
fixé effectivement les objectifs
certains ont été rappelés par mon
collègue souris des priorités etc etc et
puis comme ça n'intéresse pas grand
monde manifestement en tout cas là son
application quelques semaines après on
nous a proposé un com de la FD qui
d'ailleurs ne reprenait pas du tout les
priorités prévues par la loi puisque
c'était prévu avant donc ça
n'intéressait personne non plus ça a
continué comme ça toujours pas bien puis
ensuite tout ça s'est arrêté à peu près
en stand-bye les rapports demandés par
le Parlement ne sont jamais arrivés peu
le site se réunit quand il peut quand il
veut qu'on le président souhaite il y a
un comité présidentiel qui vient se
rajouter à tout cela j'ai envie de dire
à quoi que ce soit sert parce que la loi
du 4 août 2021 elle n'est pas appliquée
ou très peu ou même façon qu'on tournait
et allègrement et venait encore de le
démontrer tout à l'heure
donc pour pas être trop long à part
parce que d'abord première question
c'est quand allez-vous lancer les
travaux d'une nouvelle loi de
programmation ce comme elle l'essence
c'est terminé en 2025 et elle a lu on va
pour faire des pelotes de programmation
sur la plus grandement je vous conseille
de démarrer maintenant donc par exemple
c'est ce que on va pouvoir travailler
dès à présent comme ça on sera à l'heure
peut-être en 2025 cette fois-ci
deuxième chose la commission
d'évaluation moi je veux dire ce que
j'en pense très tranquillement c'est
quand on ne veut pas avoir de pilotage
politique qu'on crée une commission
d'évaluation et c'est exactement ce qui
se passe et cette fois-ci on a ni le peu
les tâches politiques ni la commission
d'évaluation parce que dans ce pays
j'aurais bien connaître les crédits des
ministères je regardais des ministères
sur l'aide publique au développement au
regard des crédits qui sont faits par
une agence
qui s'appelle AFD donc ça c'est ma
deuxième question ma troisième question
c'est qu'en est-il du rapport prêt et
dont je vous rappelle qu'on devait avoir
30% de dons 70% de prêt parce que déjà
pas énorme et j'aimerais bien savoir où
nous en sommes
je pourrais vous parler du siège de
l'AFD message je vais éviter sur la
taille sur les transactions financières
là aussi c'est une taxe qui est créée
spécifiquement pour l'aide de
complètement et ce gouvernement malgré
nos différents amendements a toujours
refusé à toujours refuser de lever le le
clapet pour faire que tout ou une partie
signification au moins 50% soit tribué
donc allez-vous oui ou non accepter
enfin accéder enfin cette demande sur la
commission d'évaluation je vous l'ai dit
on l'a dit plusieurs fois comment on
peut comprendre que on nous impose une
commission d'évaluation qui ne s'est
toujours pas réunie comme quoi était
prioritaire deux dans le débat en nous
impose qu'elles soient attachées à la
Cour des comptes moi personnellement je
n'ai pas favorable au départ enfin
maintenant elle est faite elle est faite
alors on dit maintenant c'était pour les
imprimantes etc enfin faut être c'est en
2 minutes comment se fait-il que le
gouvernement dans la voie de formation
la Financière nous avons adopté un
amendement du Gouvernement
du gouvernement indiquant que la
présidence devait être au premier
président la Cour des comptes et que le
même gouvernement a soutenu un autre
amendement à l'opposé à l'Assemblée
disant l'inverse reste des courses tout
ça est un ridicule entre maintenant des
gens qui s'écrivent et on est tous on a
tous droit à nos courriers entre un
présent de la première présidente qui
écrit le président des de la commission
d'affaires étrangère du l'assemblée
réponds ou l'un écrit l'autre répond
enfin on sait plus à la fin enfin tout
ça d'un ridicule achevé donc il faut que
globalement maintenant prennent ces
responsabilités mettent en place cette
commission et je le rappelle que il a ce
qu'à suivre la loi qu'il a fait adopter
et c'est bien la Cour des comptes donc
voilà il fallait il fallait pas il
fallait y penser avant et pour pas être
trop long et pour terminer j'aimerais
connaître la position du sur le Rwanda
est-ce que la France va au maintenant à
ouvertement condamné les agissements du
Rwanda puisque les rapports existent que
le Rwanda finance aide le M23 qui qui
massacre des gens dans l'est de la
République démocratique du Congo
sur l'intégration Nouvelle-Calédonie la
question c'est est-ce que nous allons
soutenir l'intégration notamment sur le
l'arc mélanésien etc parce que c'est ça
la question qui est posée sur l'Afrique
très honnêtement sur l'Afrique quid que
prépare la France notamment sur le
départ l'évolution de la milice Wagner
sur l'Afrique c'est plutôt comme le dit
souvent c'est pas la fin de la France
Afrique c'est plutôt la fin de la France
en Afrique donc qu'est-ce qui est prévu
concrètement sur le continent africain
voilà ce que je voulais dire rapidement
pour pas être trop long et c'est vrai
que moi j'ai le sentiment que c'est le
mystère de la parole beaucoup très bien
déplacement très bien mais j'ai pas le
sentiment que ça change la vie encore
une fois des pays sur lequel nous
travaillons je crois pas que la
psychologuement elle est en mode
automatique mais je crois pas qu'elle
soit mode de pilotage et cela nous
interroge grandement
j'espère que je n'ai que
quel est sénateur et ne pense pas que je
fais la tournée du monde comme ça mais
c'est très bien alors on commence par la
loi mais c'est les sénateurs moi si je
suis ce geste du respect du Parlement
concernant la Commission comme vous
dites la commission d'évaluation c'est
la loi je pense que c'était ramené par
vous même et
sur la question de la commission
indépendante d'évaluation et que c'était
une avancée majeure
de la loi des quatre routes et je pense
que c'est normal
qu'il y a une commission d'évaluation
car il faut avec tous les financements
qui sont dédiés il faut rendre notre
aide plus efficace et plus je le
débattable
alors les gouvernements s'est
mobilisaient de la prolongation de la
loi pour mettre en place cette
commission les degrés d'application a
été publié en mai 2022 et ce contenu les
conformes à la lettre à l'esprit de la
loi de 2021
alors le ministère des Affaires
étrangères
et les autres ministères concernaient
finalisent actuellement la proposition
de nomination des personnalités
qualifiées pour le collège d'experts
nous échangeons avec les cours de compte
pour nous assurer que les travaux de la
commission pourront être lancé deux que
les dernières poils relatif à la
gouvernance
auront été l'évêque des gouvernances
doit être acceptable par touche afin que
la Commission débute ses travaux comme
vous dites
si on attend dans la sérénité nous
prenons 6 notes du dépôts d'une
proposition de loi par les présidents
par le président bourlange
elle les ministères des Affaires
étrangères souhaite la mise en place
rapide de cette commission dans le
respect des prérogatifs des chacun
ensuite vous m'avez
sur la trajectoire vous avez dit qu'il
n'y a pas la commission d'évaluation et
après vous avez dit qu'il n'y a pas ni
politique non c'est bien
je vais vous répondre aussi sur les
politesses politiques
parce que je pense que les agences
comme vous savez très bien les agences
de tous les types ils ont aussi sont
sous tutelle même temps vous savez
qu'ils ont aussi en même temps
des initiatives alors je parle de la
trajectoire
alors et le respect de loi
tout ceci je pense nous partageons la
volonté d'y atteindre 07 des RnB à long
terme
cet objectif qui est figure dans la loi
de 2021
je pense que depuis 2021 jusqu'au
aujourd'hui il y a eu un changement
quand même au niveau mondial il est
contexte budgétaire c'est difficile
partout
mais les 07 restent notre boussole de
long terme et
pendant les CPD le président de la
République la redit
alors
j'ai le plaisir aussi de vous confirmer
qui nous avons dépassé l'objectivité
qu'il était fixé par la loi pour 2022
nous sommes comme j'ai dit à mon
discours le quatrième Bayern mondial et
pour notre pour la première fois de
notre histoire notre petite dépasse les
15 milliards d'euros nous devons garder
aussi à l'esprit qui l'indicataire
des taux d'air NBA
issue de au C2 et un instrument volatile
et principalement conçu pour comparer
les pays entre plus qui pourrait être
les reflets d'une effort budgétaire
d'ailleurs si vous voulez nos
partenaires du Sud ne nous demande
jamais l'augmentation de ces ratio c'est
que le giteresse aujourd'hui c'est le
volume de financement et à la fin les
projets concrets
alors pour les prochaines années la
volonté du Président de la République et
du gouvernement et de poursuivre cette
hausse un volume de notre APD sans faire
de ces ratio à PDR MB un outil de
pilotage au quotidien
il y a trop de certitudes pour en faire
un outil efficace et
mais voilà je pense qu'on partage la
même la même vision ensuite vous m'avez
demandé sur le rapport présent
alors à quoi sert vous avez dit les CPD
les suicides tout ça comme j'ai dit mais
si elle est célibataire je pense comme
je dis que c'est pas parce que on a fait
un suicide 2018 je dis il faut être
consciente tous qui est aujourd'hui vous
voyez aussi au niveau international et
tout et comment il a changé le monde
après l'agression rousse en Ukraine tous
les conséquences qui qu'ils ont sur
notre politique nationale et sur notre
politique internationale et je pense que
ça c'est très important c'est pour ça
aussi que CCPD si vous voulez je le
voulu personnellement pour qu'il puisse
être d'actualité et c'est pour ça aussi
que j'ai travaillé pour ce suicide et
c'est pour ça aussi que je demandais
qu'il participe voilà pourquoi alors je
tiens à CCPD je pense que c'est une
décision politique
ensuite
c'était une autre époque car il est
président suicide je pense c'était en
et depuis nous avons fait un effort
important pour mettez le financement
donne
vous vous souvenez sûrement de l'effort
exceptionnel de plus d'un milliard
d'euros à don qui vous aviez voté en loi
des finances 2019 les montants de
bilatéraux qui est mon ministère alu à
la FD dépasse désormais chaque année les
améliards sinon majeur par rapport à la
période précédente alors avec près de
0,15% de notre richesse nationale qui
bénéfice et au PMA nous sommes derrière
l'un des grands bailleurs qui flèche le
mieux c'est finalement vers les pays le
plus pauvre en même temps nous assumons
l'utilisation des prêts dans notre
politique de développement pour
financer des grands traditions et des
gants projets rectangle
et
pardon un
sourd sur ensuite sur Wagner c'est ça
je pense que
comme ces sujets je les suis dès le
début permettez-moi je suis je me suis
rendue au rang de plusieurs fois avant
d'y être ici avant d'être député comme
médecin comme député et communiste pas
encore alors j'ai dit que la station nos
Grands Lacs c'est
inquiétude internationale et par rapport
aux autres pays la France
et n'a jamais de points de mesure parce
que on s'occupe aussi de ces situations
mais bien sûr il y a beaucoup de
changements
ça veut dire que depuis l'année dernière
le président de la République il a parlé
avec tout le 2 présidents des deux pays
et aujourd'hui au niveau régional il y a
des pays les Kenya et
l'Angola qui sonne
qui s'occupent de la médiation nous
avons condamné comme vous avez dit
et
comme j'étais allée à l'ère d'essai
c'était en décembre c'était clair aussi
quand nous sommes allés avec le
président de la République
des soutiens de Rwanda au groupe M23 et
je vous rappelle aussi
que la situation il est il est très et
on la suit et oui on est je ne peux pas
vous répondre aujourd'hui pour les
sectionnes
mais dès que dès que au niveau
au niveau aussi international tous les
s'il y a les décisions comme ça je veux
pas manquer de vous tenir informé de
notre possession
après vous m'avez demandé dit Wagner
c'était quoi la question
sur le Wagner au Sahel c'était en
Afrique
bon
la situation
[Musique]
il faut dire je pense les choses telles
qui qui sonne et je pense que
en particulier on s'aime
vous savez très bien avec les Mali
la possession de la France c'est la
potion de la France on voit que les
groupes Wagner aujourd'hui ils viennent
des rapports des Nations Unies
à confirmer qui est Wagner c'est un
groupe criminel c'est un groupe mafieux
il a des méthodes pardon
c'est bien et
il y a la manipulation il y a la
prédation il y a tous les règlements de
compte qui est partout
et les selles objectives c'est des
ressources au détriment des États et des
populations et au prix comme vous avez
vu des exceptions atroces alors c'est
pour ça que ces rapports qu'il a eu le
moins 10 mai des Nations Unies qui
établit clairement la responsabilité des
Wagner dans les massacres de 5
sensibiles à Moura au Mali mais nous
nous disons au pays qui sont fait les
choix du Wagner
et
on voit bien
qui peut être
on va je pense qu'on voit qui commence à
les regretter et
qu'il y a des pays qui journaliste
dissocier
et
qui
il y a rien de bon parce qu'il y a des
inquiétudes par des autres pays que je
vais voisin de Mali qui ce qu'il y a une
grosse inquiétude pour parce que ils
veulent sortir de cette case que c'est
très dangereux pour la région par
exemple d'Israël pas seulement
voilà je pense je pense mais c'est la
terre que j'ai répondu en question
j'aurais juste pour nos collègues faire
un point précis sur la commission
d'évaluation pour leur dire exactement
quel est le problème parce que c'est une
avancée du Sénat je rappelle que c'est
le Sénat qui avait demandé et qui a
bataillé pour cette commission
d'évaluation la problématique est la
suivante
la
par une confusion d'amendements sur
lequel je vais parvenir et qu'à évoquer
j'étais mal cette commission
d'évaluation a été logé si je veux si
j'ose dire à la Cour des comptes
on nous a imposé à ce moment-là d'avoir
effectivement une référence sur un
organisme hors de tout soupçon pour son
objectif
mais un autre amendement à obligé la
Commission à élire son président et donc
le président de la Cour des comptes
refuse systématiquement une élection
puisque effectivement
dans tous les organismes dont il a peu
ou la tutelle il ne fait jamais l'objet
d'une élection on voit pas le président
de la Cour des comptes être soumet une
élection contre un autre candidat et
donc il y a eu un échange de lettres je
pense qu'un certain d'entre vous ont
reçu cet échange de courrier dire que le
président de la Cour des comptes a été
vis-à-vis de notre collègue monsieur
bourlange un peu cavalier dans dans le
ton c'est quand même pas très et pas
très pas très convenable et pas très
courtois mais donc nous sommes sur un
blocage total que j'ai moi-même évoqué
avec Madame Colona cette semaine c'est à
dire que on ne peut pas sortir de cette
affaire sans un texte législatif car la
loi maintenant est votée il lui fallut
que le secrétariat général du
gouvernement qui généralement est le
gendarme des textes puis faire attention
il y a un problème on peut pas nommer on
peut pas
domicilier votre commission à la Cour
des comptes et faire en sorte que le
président soit élu puisque le président
n'est jamais élu et donc la
revendication du président Moscou ici
est fondée la seule chose c'est qu'il y
va un peu fort dans la manière dont il
s'exprime mais je pense que
malheureusement
encore une fois moi j'ai passé une heure
avec la ministre l'autre jour et je
pense qu'elle vous en a parlé il y a il
n'y a aucune solution autre qu'un texte
législatif pour sortir de cette histoire
et le président bourlange a dit écoutez
l'histoire de la Cour des comptes il
faut que ça s'arrête dans ce cas là on
peut domicilier cette organisation au
ministère des Affaires étrangères et de
l'Europe ce qui nous paraissait plutôt
logique sauf qu'effectivement
Bercy dit ah mais non parce que nous on
veut avoir un oeil dessus par
l'intermédiaire à quoi des histoires
absolument improbable et je pense que
certains vont finir leur mandat sans
jamais voir la réunion de cette
commission et donc le président du Sénat
à ma demande
parfaite cohérence avec la semaine ça a
demandé de stopper les nominations donc
il n'y a pas de nominations de sénateurs
à cette commission tant que ce joyeux
désordre pour ne pas qualifier ça
autrement
puisse trouver une solution donc moi je
pense ma mamie ce qui va vraiment
falloir que le la première ministre ou
son directeur du cabinet lorsqu'il y en
aura un nouveau se saisisse de ce
problème car c'est un problème juridique
on peut pas violer la loi vous ne pouvez
pas vous mettre en difficulté par
rapport à ça et donc on ne peut pas
réunir la commission puisqu'il n'y a pas
de président et le Président on veut pas
être élu enfin vous voyez c'est une
histoire de
non mais je voulais que vous le sachiez
parce que c'est pour vous dire comment
parfois l'excès de c'était notre ami
Berville qui maintenant est au
gouvernement qui voulait absolument se
contrôler la Cour des comptes alors on
est bien récompensé parce que maintenant
on peut plus bouger on peut plus avancer
et comme vous l'avez très justement dit
il est absolument essentiel que le
Parlement puisse contrôler les projets
de développement et singulièrement je le
dis la FD un budget de 13 milliards sous
la responsabilité d'un directeur général
quel que soit ses mairies de personnels
qui sont immenses c'est pas ça le sujet
mais le rôle du Parlement c'est de
contrôler le gouvernement on fait ça
pour les armées
on essaye on voudrait le faire aussi sur
l'aide de développement et il faut
vraiment que vous portiez cette c'est ce
souci du Parlement de trouver une
solution qui ne peut être à mon sens à
la rentrée maintenant puisque tout est
tout est quasiment terminé pour cette
session il faudra un projet de loi ou
accepter une proposition de loi du
parlementaire pour sortir de cet un
Brolio qui fait que cette commission
risque de ne jamais voir le jour si on
continue comme ça et qu'en plus ce qui
s'écrivent
trouve le ton qui convient à ce genre
d'institution je voulais faire ce point
pour nos collègues parce qu'ils peuvent
se dire mais enfin qu'est-ce qui se
passe et voilà exactement le sujet alors
maintenant on va passer aux questions
minutes et donc je vais parce que j'ai
encore un rapport derrière donc le
président Patriat allons-y
ah non pardon madame Carlotti est notre
première excusez-moi merci monsieur le
Président pour une question minute ou
plusieurs minutes merci madame la
ministre de votre présence la CAD a
souhaité effectivement votre audition
parce qu'elle était indispensable à
quelques jours du cscite qui va se tenir
le 13 juillet prochain et je trouve
qu'il était temps qu'on se rencontre
après le Conseil présidentiel du mois de
mai dans les annonces nous ont quelque
peu inquiétés plus que les annonces les
non-dits nous ont et les oublis nous ont
inquiété et quelques jours après la
réunion du nouveau pacte financier dont
on aimerait bien savoir à quoi elle a
servi l'essentiel pour nous
parlementaire vous le savez c'est que
les engagements de la loi ça a été
largement dit tout à l'heure mais je
veux insister là-dessus que les
engagements de la loi du 4 août 2021
soit respectée vous le savez cette loi a
été adoptée de façon transpartisane à
l'unanimité de la cadèle à éliminer du
Sénat et même à l'unité de l'ensemble
des parlementaires donc il y a des
engagements c'est presque bizarre de
demander au gouvernement de respecter la
loi le premier des engagements c'est la
trajectoire financière je vous pose une
question très précise madame Premier
ministre y aura-t-il donc dans le relevé
de décision du Cécile la mention de 0,7%
du RNB pour 2025 et pas comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure une boussole à
long terme ça m'a un peu inquiété votre
remarque et effectivement attaché à ça
le maintien de la trajectoire année
après année pour en mesurer les avancées
voilà la deuxième point c'est que le
Conseil présidentiel parmi les 10
priorités il n'y a pas eu un seul mot
pour les organisations de la société
civile pas un mot alors on a compris
vous l'avez d'ailleurs développé un peu
tout à l'heure vous semblez vouloir
fonder davantage la politique de
développement sur le secteur privé
certes on a besoin d'investissement mais
on a encore plus besoin du travail sur
le long terme que réalise les
associations la loi fixe comme objectif
d'atteindre la moyenne des pays de
l'OCDE pour leur financement on en est
loin et alors qu'il s'agit quand même de
rattrapage et que nous ne voulons pas en
rester là donc ma deuxième question est
très précise aussi est-ce que le Sissi
du 13 juillet va conforter cette
prescription de la loi le troisième
point le 8 mars dernier vous aviez
annoncé la création d'un fond de soutien
aux organisations féministes c'est très
bien c'est un formidable outil qui est
salué par l'ensemble de la société
civile vous y avez proposé 120 millions
je crois sur trois ans ma question c'est
pourquoi sur trois ans est-ce que vous
envisagez de le pérenniser après aussi
entre points pouvez-vous vous engager
que dans le Sicile on ne conditionne pas
et dans aucun des déclarations du
gouvernement on ne conditionne pas à
l'aide au développement à la politique
migratoire que pratique la France avec
les États concernés enfin je finis sur
ce point c'est peut-être un peu le plus
long monsieur le Président mais il est
très important à quoi a servi le sommet
de Paris d'autant que les États-Unis n'y
étaient pas lors des débats sur le
nouveau pacte financier il a été
souligné qu'il fallait revoir le mandat
des banques de développement et puis
trouver de nouvelles sources de
financement alors ce qui nous concerne
nous sommes tout à fait d'accord pour
travailler ça a été dit tout à l'heure
sur des financements innovants nous
sommes bien contents qui est une taxe
sur les billets d'avion nous sommes très
contents mais nous voulons aller plus
loin et nous avons fait des propositions
sur la taxe sur les transactions
financières et nous sommes prêts à
réfléchir et à travailler sur une taxe
sur les transports maritimes au titre du
pollueur-payeur sur le premier point
notre commission a défendu la
modification de notre aide au
développement faveur des dons j'ai pas
développé plus de dons et moins de près
ça a été dit tout à l'heure pour
renforcer les PMA et les services
sociaux de base est-ce que vous allez
continuer et appuyer cette tendance on
sait non mais je veux finir
ben oui
deux heures ou deux heures hier voilà
mais ça ne suffira pas je termine par là
je vous prie de m'excuser de nombreuses
États africains aujourd'hui sont au bord
du gouffre ils sont dans surendettement
ils n'arrivent pas il pleut sur leur
dette qu'ils ont beaucoup empruntés
auprès de la Chine si la France veut
retrouver un peu de crédibilité auprès
des Africains est-ce qu'elle devrait pas
agir au sein de l'Union européenne et
c'est de votre compétence pour proposer
des solutions pour venir en aide aux
populations construire des hôpitaux des
infrastructures des écoles etc est-ce
que vous pouvez pas travailler dans ce
sens je passe sur la commission
d'évaluation mais je voulais simplement
vous dire qu'à ce stade madame la
ministre je finis par là
je voudrais vous dire respectueusement
madame du ministre qu'on a l'impression
que le gouvernement se moque de nous
nous avons prévu dans l'article 3 que il
y avait avant le 1er juin de chaque
année le gouvernement devait nous
transmettre un rapport complet sur notre
action en termes d'aide au développement
rien il devait également avec la fin de
l'année 2022 donner un tableau actualisé
sur les cibles rien et dans la lignée à
14 de cet article 3 il devait prévoir un
débat en séance à l'Assemblée et au
Sénat rien quand est-ce que cette loi va
être respectée alors qu'elle a été votée
par l'ensemble des parlementaires
veillez chers collègues les uns et les
autres non mais je comprends très bien
que chacun ait des questions sur un
sujet qui est tout à fait essentiel mais
voilà bon madame la ministre essayez de
répondre sur ces différents merci
beaucoup
là alors
l'Afrique vu que quand je vous j'écoute
je pense qu'on fait rien et c'est je
trouve je suis désolée mais
je vais expliquer alors vu que que vous
n'avez pas compris à quoi elle desservée
les pattes alors on va mettre on va
expliquer
à quoi il était utile ses pacte
financière
c'était comme je vous expliquais si vous
suivez les sujets au niveau des
financements on crée toujours de
nouveaux fonds
et les personnes leur vie sans changent
pas et de l'autre côté il y a les
personnes du développement
que ils disent de changer alors et
c'était les moments de travailler à
sable alors il y a eu quatre groupes de
travail
qui travaillent qu'ils ont commencé à
travailler sous des questions la dette
que vous avez très bien souligné et qui
je n'ai pas pardon que je suis très fier
sur ça de dire le travail qui fait les
claps de Paris parce que c'est la France
qui la rôle fondamental qu'il est
reconnu par tous les pays africain alors
je peux pas vous laisser dire que sur
ces questions
que la France ne fait rien non je
parlais de la Zambie je parle des Ghana
on sait très bien que les pays africains
sont endettés c'est les pays sont
endettés vous m'avez demandé je vous
réponds si vous voulez madame la
sénatrice alors les pays sont endettés
il y a une histoire très fort il était
et
sur ça alors oui la France elle est
reconnue partout pour son rôle alors
autre chose à quoi elle s'était
important la question de la dette
la question c'est chaque fois les clubs
de Paris travaillent comment on peut
pérenniser ce mécanismes vous comprenez
on peut pas chaque pays par exemple
quand on parle avec les pays africains
des pâtes dépendre chaque fois dans
négociation
c'est pas que aussi c'était comment on
peut travailler ensemble
autre chose sur les pacte sous les
nouveaux financements
oui on a besoin l'argent public il est
connu que il ne peut pas résoudre tout
la pauvreté du monde c'est impossible la
question c'est quand vous avez dit je
comprends les rôles de tous les acteurs
mais vous avez parlé des secteur privé
oui il est secteur privé il faut en qui
investi et deux qui assume aussi qui
partagent c'est pour ça aussi et la
France quand il a eu la proposition pour
d'accès les Maritimes on a dit on n'est
pas contre à Londres à ces moments-là il
y a des discussions sur ça sur la DTF
comme je dis nous on est exemplaire
alors il faut aussi que les autres
suivent
alors voilà et vous avez parlé de
l'Europe alors j'ai dit aujourd'hui que
soit la France qui soit l'Europe
l'Europe s'est en première bailleur il
est financier et je vous l'ai dit parce
que j'étais député européenne je vous le
dis aussi aujourd'hui à ma possession la
question de l'Europe oui il a eu il a un
programme sur les grandes phrases
structures comme je vous ai dit 150
milliards pour l'Afrique et ça c'est pas
rien et n'est pas négligeable la
question n'est que chaque fois nous les
Européennes et on le voit tout le temps
je le vois on n'est pas capable d'avoir
cette fierté et de dire à non partenaire
aussi ça que nous faisons c'est pas
parce qu'il y a un stade avec un drapeau
et d'une autre pays que c'est ça on est
là on est là pour les questions de
l'éducation on est pas seulement pour
construire des écoles mais aussi la
question de la formation c'est des
choses avec des des techniques pour les
aider à mettre en place les projets
alors non sur ça je suis très claire et
et la France et l'Europe est travaillée
sur ça et sur les questions de la dette
et sur les questions des infrastructures
et pas seulement et sous les questions
de la sécurité tous ensemble au niveau
européen on est tous mobilisé ensuite
la question sur
vous m'avez dit aussi que les États-Unis
n'étaient pas présents je suis désolée
les États-Unis la dame la secrétaire de
définir madame Yellen qu'elle propose la
réforme des banques mondiales elle était
là de les débuts sur le ministère et
tout le ministration américaine il a
travaillé pendant 4 mois et en plus si
vous voyez je vous envoie de voir la
conférence de presse du Président de la
République avec les présidents Naruto
avec la secrétaire Yellen et et vous
allez voir alors que les États-Unis
étaient la présente parce que sans les
États-Unis
on ne peut pas avancer et c'est ça qui
est je disais la place de la France et
il y a une elle était là et les
premières minutes chinois il était là et
voilà
c'est les langages de ce sommets il est
pris aujourd'hui vous pouvez aller à
regarder
le langage du sommeil il est repris par
les États-Unis alors ensuite
à la société civile voilà quelqu'un qui
vient de la société civile comme moi
comment je peux alors pas avoir au cœur
de mon action la société civile je vais
vous envoyer alors
en rapport que je fais que j'ai publié
avec la société civile parce que je
travaille tout en avec eux et
vous m'avez parlé de fond de soutien
organisation féministe ça tombe bien
parce que c'est moi-même c'est c'était
un des principaux de financières de
notre diplomatie féministe il a été
annoncé à 2019 par les présidents de la
République avec 120 millions sur trois
ans et moi même j'étais fier de annoncer
à cet dernière madame la sénatrice à New
York la poursuite de cet instrument
innovant ok alors et au service des
activistes et des organisations et je
pense que ces séances de 3 ans parce que
pérennisait j'écoute souvent ces mots
pérenniser sans vent trois ans de
nouveau 3 ans ça aussi alors oui c'est
important pour voir parce que on a fait
une réunion on a discuté comment on peut
aussi comment on peut faire mieux mais
les financements sur les organisations
sont là et c'était comme je vous ai dit
annoncé
ensuite
et en plus c'est fond a fait ses preuves
parce que il a soutenu plus de 1000
associations féministes qui est le père
dans nos pays partenaires a plus de 80%
sur les continents africains 133
millions d'euros on était mobilisés
comme je vous dis depuis 2020 et on
continue et
ça c'était les organisations
sur l'organisation oui je voulais
vraiment sous la société civile je vais
vous envoyer les rapports qui en a
publié qui on a fait la société civile
et moi-même pour vous dire que sonne
comme on dit
partout où je veux c'est avec eux que je
travaille et alors permettez-moi de dire
que
sur ces sujets aussi je suis très
contente merci Madame ministre monsieur
patriar
une question à 20 secondes merci Madame
la Ministre alors je viens de nous
rassurez-vous nous n'avons pas le
sentiment que le gouvernement se moque
de nous voilà mais je vous dis comme ça
plaisantant bien entendu non simplement
une question un peu différente la guerre
la guerre en Ukraine crée des troubles
logistiques graves dans les marchés
suite difficulté qu'il y a dans la mer
Noire qui est le principal point
d'alimentation pour les pays à la fois
du Moyen-Orient et puis de l'Afrique du
Nord
vous savez que l'Ukraine
et de crème et la Russie fournissent en
matière de blé de tournesol de céréales
sur le plus gros fournisseur du monde
aujourd'hui et cet état de fait créer
une insécurité alimentaire ma question
est la suivante quel est le rôle de la
France pour aujourd'hui essayer de
lutter contre cette insécurité
alimentaire
merci président
comme vous dites
la l'agression neuro ça nous craignent
il a montré partout au monde là question
de la
l'importance de la sécurité alimentaire
l'importance de la souveraineté
alimentaire la France a fait de la
sécurité la souveraineté alimentaire
mondiale une priorité politique
vous savez que
sous la présidence française je me
souviens j'étais député européenne quand
le président de la République en marche
mars
et la présenter
l'initiative farm et une action forte
après ensuite je vous les engrais au
total l'année 2022 nous avons mobilisé
700 millions dans les domaines la France
alors agit sur le plan au magnétère mais
aussi sous les longues termes comme je
vous disais avec une mobilisation aussi
de notre secteur privé et aussi celui
européenne au voyage par exemple au
déplacement du président continue
africain il a eu il a eu cette
engagement pour qu'il puisse commencer à
produire et même
en Afrique
produit et on les a on les a pille
aujourd'hui aux pratiques
agroécologiques et la structuration des
filières agricoles
ensuite face à la montée aussi de la
femme de la malnutrition parce que c'est
un vrai sujet aujourd'hui la
malnutrition dans le monde la France a
multiplié par 5 à 5 ans
et cette année s'élève à plus de 150
millions parce que je disais que c'est
très important de parler de la
malnutrition la sur notre chaîne en
particulier maternel et infantile
après vous savez qui est un lien avec
les Jeux olympiques de Paris on aurait
aussi la prochaine édition du sommet
nutrition pour la croissance
fin 2024 au début 2025 et la France
aussi à la fin c'est quelque chose que
je suis personnellement la France
soutient les programmes d'alimentation
scolaire vous savez au continent
africain c'est très important parce que
les enfants qu'ils ont la magie à
l'école ils vont pas aller à travailler
ils vont pouvoir avoir accès à
l'éducation
alors
et ça c'est c'est
une vraie lutte l'éducation des filles
et ça passe par l'alimentation scolaire
alors je suis aussi contente d'y
annoncer qui est nous allons acquérir la
première réunion mondiale pour la
Coalition pour l'alimentation scolaire
avec la filante ici le mois je pense le
mois de octobre et vous êtes bien sûr
tous
à inviter à ce moment
merci Madame la Ministre allez Jacques
le nez avançons merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre en janvier
dernier la France et l'Allemagne ont
décidé de coopérer plus étroitement lors
de crise mondiale ainsi qu'au sujet de
la réforme de la Banque mondiale
considérez-vous que les efforts
internationaux en matière de
développement et plus particulièrement
européen sont suffisamment coordonnées
et complémentaires deux stratégies ont
guidé l'action de la France en matière
de développement depuis 2018 la
stratégie prévention résilience et paix
durable et la stratégie humanitaire de
la France qui s'étale toutes deux sur la
période 2018-2022 est-il prévu
d'actualiser ces stratégies pour les
années à venir ainsi que de tirer des
conclusions sur la période écoulée
merci madame la ministre
merci beaucoup de votre question mais
c'est
vous avez parlé justement
il y a des octobre
octobre 2022 qui j'étais à Washington et
il y a la question de la réforme de la
Banque mondiale qu'il était beaucoup
porté comme je disais par les États-Unis
par Madame Yellen mais dans ces cas
aussi au niveau européen car j'étais
vous avez parlé de la France et de
l'Allemagne mais j'étais moi-même à
cette discussion avec tous mes collègues
de tous les pays et sur cette
réforme de la masse mondiale je peux
vous dire que nous nous allons vers la
même direction
La Réunion
de printemps de la marque mondiale et
des FMI qu'il a eu lieu le mois d'avril
était une première étape essentielle sur
ce du processus de la réforme de la
banque alors
comme je disais les gouvernères ils ont
retenus deux points qui nous partageons
avec avec les Allemands l'intégration
des biens publics mondiaux dans la
mission du Bank et le deuxième c'est
l'adoption du premier paquet financier
qui reprend certains recommandations
liées au cadre des adéquations du
capital alors ces premières paquets
qu'il était annoncé le mois d'avril
c'est 50 milliards
qui va augmenter de sa 4 milliards la
capacité de près de la marque mondiale
sur les 10 process année alors
bien sûr nous ne sommes pas au bout des
seins qui va être longue mais
je pense que ça qu'on partage beaucoup
pas seulement avec les Allemands aussi
avec les autres européennes et on a pu
le constater aussi il y a des semaines à
Paris mais aussi tous les discussions
qui ont fait et vous savez il y a un
nouveau président de la Banque mondiale
et qu'il était élu aussi avec notre
soutien qui est il interviennent au
moment crucial pour pour l'organisation
et il montre des signes encourageants
pour agir lui-même pour faire avancer
avec des mesures très ambitieux et sur
ça oui
France Allemagne travaillait vraiment
à manière coordonnée parce qu'on a
besoin aussi d'une coordination au
niveau européenne
ensuite vous m'avez parlé de la
stratégie humanitaire
qu'il était
2018-2022 et que vous savez
les domanitaires restent une
reste une priorité très fort on va
partout on est présente y compris
aujourd'hui vous avez vu au Soudan et
partout et je pense
avec les suicides
je pense que il faut
confirmer et renforcer cette priorité et
à augmenter les moyens voilà
merci nous avançons avec Michel Gréau
merci
par une lettre d'attente du 13 mars la
ministre des Affaires étrangères
Catherine Colonna s'est adressée à
François Rebsamen président de citer
uni-france au sujet de la coopération
décentralisée entre la France et le Mali
dans cette lettre le meae remet en
question les projets de coopération
portés par certaines collectivités aux
motif que le gouvernement malien a
interdit par décret tout projet de
développement bénéficiant
bénéficiant d'un financement de la
France outre le fait que cette décision
fut prise suite à la décision de la
France comme le regrettait à juste titre
les organisations humanitaires de
suspendre toutes les aides au
développement au Mali je souhaite ici
rappeler qu'une collectivité
territoriale ne relève pas du droit
international mais du droit interne
autrement dit une commune agit en son
nom propre est né en aucun cas liée à la
politique étrangère de la France tant
que la commune respecte bien entendu les
traités et accords de la France c'est
pourquoi madame la ministre cette lettre
me met profondément mal à l'aise car en
demandant aux collectivité de redéployer
les aides initialement prévues au Mali
vers d'autres pays cela suscite le
sentiment d'un retour à la logique
archaïque d'une tutelle de l'État sur
les collectivités je souhaite rappeler
qu'il revient collectivité de décider en
toute souveraineté et à l'abri de toute
pression de la poursuite au nom de leur
action de solidarité internationale il
n'est pas souhaitable que le pouvoir
français lit les collectivités
territoriales au turpitude et variations
de la politique étrangère de la France
de manière directe et contribuer ainsi à
les discréditer au Mali et dans la
sous-région j'aimerais donc savoir si
vous confirmez la possibilité pour nos
communes de poursuivre leur projet de
coopération décentralisée vers le Mali
merci
précise
merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup madame la sénatrice
effectivement je vous remercie aussi
parce que en posant ces questions vous
mettez au centre de la question la
question des rôles de l'école
territoriales qui sont très importants
quand on parle
de la coopération
internationale concernant le Mali
alors là je suis un peu
un petit peu
je vais vous dire je sais pas si vous
avez suivi les maladies comment il
traite notre pays simplement je vous dis
je sais pas comment vous avez vu on est
sur unique comme on est traité mais
effectivement
la situation Mali c'est très difficile
et parce que l'attitude de la de la
gente malienne qui s'alliait avec la
milice du Wagner
je pense que c'est très grave et nous
estimons que les conditions n'étaient
plus réunies pour la poursuite de nos
projets d'aide publique au développement
et il avait un grand risque de
détournement des financements
et c'est pour ça aussi nous avons
cependant dit on va maintenir notre aide
d'urgence et notre action humanitaire
c'était ça notre décision ensuite
c'est pas la France qui a décidé de
mettre fin par exemple à son aide
humanitaire Mali c'est la jante c'est la
même jante et nous on a dit qu'on
regrette la décision des autorités
maliennes des interdire tous les
activités menées par les organisations
nos gouvernementales tous les ONG qui
soient qui recevable finalement français
qui soit français qui soit local qui
soit international
et je pense
je pense que vous savez qu'un pays fait
un choix le pays c'est souvent
et
l'agent a fait ce soir brutal
à de faveur de sa population mais c'est
pas la nôtre
et parce que je pense que historiquement
toujours nous étions à côté de la
population malienne
alors
si vous voulez depuis 2013 je ne veux
pas parler
nos militaires qui se sont sacrifiés
leur vie pour la liberté de Mali je dis
aussi
on a consacré plus de 100 millions
d'euros
à l'éducation alors je l'ai dit et
devant vous mais je l'ai dit aussi
devant les collectivités territoriales
de coopération française mis un défaut
notamment nos coopérations de cette
réaliser sera étudié au cas par cas par
les services de notre ministère voilà
merci alors nous avons souvent avec
Guillaume Gontard
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre je vais essayer de
poursuivre avec des avec des questions
précises et puis peut-être qu'il
complèteront cette coin déjà été posé on
avait inscrit dans la loi le seuil de 85
% de projets de la ayant pour
objectif principal ou significatif
l'égalité famome d2025 et donc je
voulais savoir si selon vous cet
objectif sera atteint c'est dans deux
ans et qu'est-ce qui est mis réellement
en oeuvre pour pour y arriver mais
savoir également quels sont les mesures
prises pour renforcer la transparence
dans l'utilisation de la et dans la
suite de la question de
Carlotti qu'est-ce qui met en place
notamment pour renforcer le rôle des
organisations société civiles au sein
des États partenaires de la et puis
pour terminer une question plus plus
précise suite à notre interpellation on
a eu la suspension temporaire du projet
de financer le parc de kawsi biégal en
République de monnaie de critique du
Congo et ça a été annoncé par la
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères est-ce que ce projet de
financement a été définitivement
abandonné parce que à ce jour on n'a pas
d'éléments précis pour attester que ce
projet est totalement abandonné merci
merci beaucoup pour votre question alors
la première question c'était la question
de l'égalité et les décorations de
l'enjeu de l'un de gens et de l'égalité
femme homme dans notre politique du
développement
et effectivement c'est la grande
priorité du gouvernement depuis 2017 et
cela bien sûr reste une de mes priorités
comme je disais à votre collègue j'avais
annoncé à New York cette
pushuite des trois prochaines années de
notre fond de soutien les ONG féministes
que c'est vraiment un instrument très
innovant
mais aussi
l'état fixe par ailleurs des objectifs
très ambitieux à ces opérateurs l'AFD
l'expertise France et en matière de de
financement consacré à l'égalité femme
alors bien sûr que les processus
intégral pleinement cet Angèle
fondamental et
je pense que comme je disais que
on est on est au rendez-vous en 2022 via
notre agence de développement nous avons
engagé 249 nouveaux projets et 5,1
milliard d'euros en faveur de l'égalité
famome presque 20% des projets de live
des fonds de l'égalité de gens leur
objectif principal avec et
derrière les chiffres il y a des projets
il y a des projets concrets
et je pense en magnifique programme de
12 millions pour appuyer les femmes
entrepreneuses en RDC ou à la Fondation
pensée pour la prise en charge des
victimes de violence sexuelles ça c'est
pour la politique après
et ensuite vous m'avez demandé pour le
parc non le parc national a l'air de ces
qu'il a été annoncé par la ministre
colonne à la nation du projet
les gouvernements congolais nous avaient
sollicité pour appuyer ce projet à
travers des communautaires vivant autour
de cette part que tout après servant la
biodiversité et lors de ces examens de
ces dossiers et il y a des soupçons qui
ont été émergées concernant le respect
de la population autochtone alors avec
la ministre alors nous avions donné nous
avons donc décidé l'été dernière de
demander à l'AFD des suspendre
l'instruction de ces projets
et alors il est aujourd'hui abandonné
conformément notre exigence de respect
des droits humains et bien sûr ça ne
remet pas en cause
l'engagement de la France pour la
protection des forêts du Bassin du coco
de la RDC vous savez que
le mois de mars on avait fait au Gabon
comme je disais
un sommet avec des avec
une mobilisation aussi des financements
des financements aussi privés
pour
les bassins du Congo et encore plus
la relation bilatérale qui en est avec
l'air des célébrer fort alors via la FD
pour le période
2022-2025 on a investit plus de 500
millions dans la RDC
encore du collègues madame
moi je voudrais vous remercier Madame la
Ministre parce que nous avions besoin
d'un changement ensuite au changement de
paradigme d'avoir un vrai dialogue qui
soit un dialogue différencié envers ces
états dont certains nous en veulent et
je j'apprécie votre approche d'humilité
face à ces accusations d'arrogance qui
nous ont souvent été infligés qui nous
sont extrêmement préjudiciables
maintenant ma question est précise et
aussi pardon je voudrais aussi vous
remercier pour lorsque vous avez dit
qu'il était important de vous appuyer
aussi sur les parlementaires parce que
nous sommes nous voyageons beaucoup en
particulier les Français de l'étranger
et nous pouvons vous aider efficacement
vous avez mentionné la Papouasie
Nouvelle Guinée j'y étais il y a deux
trois ans j'étais désespéré de voir
qu'il n'y avait plus d'alliance
française qu'il n'y avait plus une seule
offre d'enseignement du français y
compris pour les diplomates qui en avait
bien besoin et c'est important j'ai fait
remonter je ne sais pas trop pour on en
est maintenant peut-être que vous
pourriez nous le dire ma question
précise porte chiot l'Ukraine je suis
allée deux fois depuis le début de la
guerre non seulement pour mon travail
pour l'Assemblée parlementaire de l'OTAN
mais aussi pour promouvoir l'image de la
France en vue de la reconstruction du
pays parlé de nos entreprises et il y a
une vraie attente des Ukrainiens très
forte il y a des besoins énormes de
reconstruction gestion des eaux
ferroviaires construction et nous sommes
totalement absents il y a des appels
d'offres nous ne sommes pas présents
contrairement aux Allemands
contrairement au Britannique et ça c'est
inadmissible surtout quand on voit les
efforts que nous faisons alors il y a
des solutions premièrement l'Ukraine me
semble-t-il ne devrait plus être classé
en zone rouge mais en zone orange en
dehors bien sûr de la zone qui est voilà
que l'on connaît tout à fait à l'est
parce que pardon mais autour de Kiev la
situation n'est pas si dangereuse que ça
et ne justifie pas vraiment cette zone
rouge qui empêche aussi des Français
d'amener leur famille avec eux alors
même que nous avons une petite école
française premier poids deuxième point
c'est aussi une demande du ménage la FFD
n'a toujours pas demandé clair en
Ukraine et le réclame alors c'est urgent
mesdames la ministre l'AFD a par exemple
ouvert un bureau en Moldavie en 2021 qui
est extrêmement
utile et il n'y a toujours rien en
Ukraine donc Madame la Ministre s'il
vous plaît aidez-nous parce qu'il faut
qu'on avance c'est urgence sinon nous ne
raterons pas le retard face à nos
concurrents allemands et britanniques
merci
alors une réponse sur l'Ukraine voilà je
suis
je veux pas répondre sous l'Ukraine
parce que je je veux pas vous répondre
sur la crème parce que c'est le dossier
qui suit la ministre pour être honnête
je vais être honnête parce que c'est
j'ai aussi dans mon dossier il y a des
prérogatives sur l'Ukraine et les gérée
par la ministre catalogue et vous savez
très bien qui est il a été nommé un
envoyé spécial qui s'occupe de la
reconstruction
et
simplement je vais souligner
que
vous m'avez posé la question sous la FD
vous savez que vous vous avez parlé de
l'Ukraine monnaie regardez aussi par les
restes du monde moi je vais vous dire je
vais partager avec vous que je suis allé
en Afrique aujourd'hui ils disent 600
000 mortes en Éthiopie
le Sahel autre morte à la au grand lac
de Georges
on est critiqué
[Musique]
il y a il y a un risque d'effet
d'éviction
moi j'ai je pardon
moi je je suis ce sauge
c'est pas pris encore la décision
sur la question
je vous dis mais là vraiment avec tous
les respects que je peux vous ça c'est
la question à poser à la ministre
colonne et
et
ensuite
vous m'avez parlé c'est ça non
on a une dernière question de Joël
guerriot oui très rapidement madame
madame la ministre nous sommes dans une
période où nous pensons qu'il faut
revenir au calme et ne pas mettre de
l'huile sur le feu or la porte-parole du
Haut commissariat de l'ONU au droit de
l'homme interpelle la France demande que
s'attaque aux questions de racisme dans
les forces de l'ordre ce qui évidemment
nous a particulièrement choqué et
j'aimerais avoir votre avis en
particulier du fait que vous avez en
charge les partenariats internationaux
et dans ce contexte là quel est votre
point de vue sur ces prises de position
et c'est le Ministre Darmanin je pense
qu'il faut que vous interpellez mais
c'est destinataire sur cette question
oui je suis partenariat international
mais je ne suis pas le ministre Darmanin
Istre merci effectivement c'est une
audition tonique parce que c'est un
sujet que la commission des affaires
étrangères et de la défense porte depuis
longtemps nous avons le
nous avons un sentiment vous avez pu le
comprendre et vous n'êtes pas
directement responsable étant arrivé il
y a un an mais nous avons quand même un
sentiment général d'insatisfaction
par rapport à l'action du gouvernement
qui n'a peut-être pas pris assez en
compte le travail que nous avions fait
sur cette loi j'ai eu l'occasion de vous
le dire bon il y a ce c'est abcès que
constitue la Commission de la Commission
de d'experts mais d'une manière générale
lorsque nous avons procédé à des
auditions avec le directeur général de
l'AFD on a toujours eu beaucoup de mal à
tenter d'imprimer notre point de vue ça
a été rappelé par les rapporteurs
vous savez on a cité ces exemples quand
on quand on voit les problèmes qui se
posent dans le reste du monde et que
qui sont là la FD prête des centaines de
millions à la Chine c'est une question a
été posée à de multiples reprises donc
je crois que au-delà de la tonicité des
questions mais qui est bien naturelle je
crois qu'il y a la volonté d'agir pour
que l'action de la France dont on ne
méconnait pas l'importance de l'effort
on voit très bien les progressions de
crédit qui sont intervenus mais je pense
qu'une nouvelle fois une fois de plus le
Parlement demande un meilleur contrôle
de ses actions c'est notre vocation
constitutionnelle et donc il ne faut pas
hésiter à
soi même solliciter des auditions soit
en tous les cas nous donner les
renseignements et le faire pour les
rapporteurs au moment des budgets et
faire en sorte que cette loi du 4 août
2021 soit enfin appliqué parce que
véritablement nous portons ça un peu
comme une forme d'humiliation alors
qu'on avait apporté beaucoup sur ce
texte et en racheter mal la évoqué on a
l'impression toujours d'un décalage
entre toutes ces institutions conseils
présidentiel du développement sissibles
etc bon puis alors nous on est on essaie
d'aller dans le bon sens y compris avec
la diplomatie parlementaire avec le
travail que nous soutenons des
collectivités territoriales mais on a
l'impression un petit peu de parler dans
le vide donc c'est pour ça que les
échanges ont
pu être à la hauteur de ce que nous
attendons cette audition madame la
ministre merci infiniment d'avoir
accepté ce rendez-vous et aurons
l'occasion au moment des budgets de de
nous retrouver sur ces sur ces points je
vous en prie
mais c'est le président
merci beaucoup moi je suis prête un tout
d'abord comme j'ai dit à travailler et
j'étais député européenne alors
on partage beaucoup de choses et
shoulaké shaun de contrôle vous savez on
a échangé nos deux je tiens beaucoup et
j'étais aussi toussé par les sources
qu'il a dit votre collègue qu'il n'y a
pas contre politique je peux vous dire
que
une politique
Syrie une politique où il y a beaucoup
des artères mais c'est les sénateurs
pour la coordonnées vous par la
chirurgienne maintenant je fais tous les
forts pour coordonner mais vous savez il
y a des habitudes il y a des précarès
c'est comme notre politique quand on va
en Afrique et alors tout ça je peux vous
dire que je m'applique
100% 24/24 pour mettre autour de la
table et le président ici c'est parce
que j'ai l'informe pour mettre tous les
artères autour de la table alors ça vous
pouvez après la loi bien sûr et c'est
normal c'est la loi il faut être
respecté le CPD et le CPD et les
suicides comme vous avez dit c'est pas
une opposition de la loi au contraire
moi j'ai poussé pour le CPD pour que
cette loi qui l'a dans l'esprit de la
loi pour avancer pour prioriser pour
dire OK dans une loi il y a tout
aujourd'hui on a aussi quelques
priorités on va avancer avec plus de
priorité en respectant bien chez la loi
mais c'est inocit une façon
un d'intéresser tout le monde pas
seulement nous qu'on s'occupe mais
t'intéressait tous les collègues tous
les sociétés civiles pour faire pour
pouvoir aussi
instaurer un dialogue et pour moi
c'était important ça voilà c'est pas la
loi contre les cpdo CPD contre la loi
c'était pas cet esprit voilà ça je
voulais vous dire et bien sûr et bien
sûr
j'espère qu'il y a cette commission de
contrôle le plus vite possible ça ça
comme un des ça non et aussi et aussi
avec ce nouveau si je peux dire avec ce
nouveau
suicide quelque chose que je voulais que
je voulais pousser je pense qu'il y a
deux sénateurs qui ont demandé
oui j'ai insisté au CP au Conseil
présidentiel j'ai expliqué au président
de la République et c'est très important
d'avoir autour les trésors
les deux ministères avoir la FD et faire
aussi sacs
réunion pour avoir aussi à la fin une
fois par an avec le 2 ministres vous
voilà j'ai j'ai je peux vous promettre
que mon engagement il est total merci
des nouveaux souhaitons bonne chance
nous souhaitons surtout que vous
puissiez imposer votre autorité à tous
ces organismes notamment à l'AFD parce
que et nous sommes c'est le même sujet
que nous évoquons depuis toujours et
nous vous connaissez la position et du
président et de la commission c'est un
organisme quand même richement de thé
comme peu de ministère
en nom et il convient que cette autorité
ministérielle elle soit respectée et que
ce soit autour de vous que les
directions puissent être prises et je
pense que
si de surcroît on arrive à faire
appliquer cette loi on pourra nourrir
notre dialogue merci encore infiniment
madame Lamy quelques quelques instants
de suspension avant d'en finir avec un
dernier rapport que nous avons examiné